es war im juli des letzten jahres es war
bundestagswahlkampf in deutschland
christian lindner präsentierte sich
selber als die idealbesetzung für den
posten des finanzministers der mit allen
mitteln neue schulden verhindern will
selbstbeschränkung der politik bisschen
so wie und die chance wer sich sie
erinnern sich an den mast gebunden hat
damit er den sirenen klängen nicht
erlegt so ähnlich geht's politikern auch
immer verführt in wahlkämpfen
zusätzlichen dinge zu versprechen die
schuldenbremse ist wie bei open source
die bindung an die solidität und an die
interessen der nächsten generation ein
knappes jahr später christian lindner
ist finanzminister und von und dessous
standhaftigkeit keine spur alle
versprechen sind gebrochen lindner
verantwortet die bisher zweithöchste
schuldenaufnahme des bundes muss
milliarden bereitstellen für das
sogenannte sondervermögen bundeswehr
hinzu kommen neue schulden für die
entlastung der bürger für die bekämpfung
der inflation
wir müssen wirklich sehen dass wir
rauskommen aus dieser verschuldung serie
wir müssen klar zurück kommen zur
schuldenbremse und müssen weitere
entlastungen anteilen weil wir auch
nicht wissen wie lange das mit der
inflation jetzt noch so weitergeht und
wir müssen es aber in zukunft jetzt so
machen das nicht für jeden ampel partner
irgendwie was dabei ist die fdp setzte
den tank rabatt durch doch dieser zeigt
bisher wenig wirkung die preise an den
tankstellen kaum gesunken spd und grüne
fordern eine über gewinn steuer unter
anderem für mineralölkonzerne den der
ukraine krieg außergewöhnliche gewinne
gebracht hat das ist unanständig und das
treibt auch unsere gesellschaft
auseinander und genau hier könnte eine
über gewinn steuer eingreifen es ist
nicht gerecht nicht vermittelbar dass
viele menschen jetzt leiden unter der
kassen inflation und sich einige
konzerne die taschen voll schlagen man
muss sich dann auch die fdp bewegen doch
eine neue steuer mit der fdp nicht zu
machen hektisch geradezu hilflos agiert
die ampel derzeit neun euro ticket tank
rabatt tipps fürs energiesparen die
inflation steigt auf nie dagewesene
höhen über 73 prozent waren es im märz 8
prozent werden erwartet nicht länger
abwarten will der wirtschaftsminister er
kündigte vor zwei stunden an ein gesetz
vorzulegen zur stärkung des kartellamtes
um das abschöpfen von über gewinnen zu
erleichtern habe gegen lindner die
debatte über die steuer twitter ja zu
einem raum aber nun will ich auch nicht
warten solange sie da im raum steht er
mich nicht bewegen jetzt habe ich einen
weg aufgezeigt wie wir das über das
kartellrecht angehen können leider das
muss man ehrlicherweise zu sagen dazu
sagen gilt das nicht für die gegenwart
die rechte sind noch nicht geschaffen
worden wir müssen uns an recht und
gesetz halten aber für die zukunft so
bald wie es geht machen wir das auch
von der opposition gibt es derzeit viele
ideen wie die eigentliche ursache der
inflation die steigenden energiepreise
bekämpft werden kann wir brauchen wie es
ja schon mal vorhanden war eine
staatliche kontrolle der energiepreise
wir brauchen ein deckel auf die
energiepreise der staatlich kontrolliert
wird und natürlich müssen auch die
kernkraftwerke es darf kein tabu sein
dass sie wieder angeschaltet werden dass
die kohlekraftwerke zumindest temporär
wieder angeschaltet werden man muss das
auch die gaskraftwerke natürlich die
regierung will dass er alles abschalten
vorschläge also gibt es reichlich klar
ist bisher nur die weitere entlastung
der bürger der kampf gegen die inflation
wird viel geld kosten ohne neue schulden
dürfte es kaum geben die spd definiert
schulden daher ganz neu
schulden sind auch unterlassene
investitionen ins bildungssystem in die
gesundheitsversorgung in die digitale
infrastruktur in deutschland deswegen
sind viele dieser maßnahmen und gelder
die wir jetzt in bewegung setzen aus
unserer perspektive keine schulden im
engeren sinne sondern ist dass es ist
das aufholen von unterlassenen
investitionen der letzten jahrzehnte für
den finanzminister dürfte es zudem
schwieriger werden seine versprochene
selbstbeschränkung der politik die
schuldenbremse wirklich einzuhalten
und bei mir ist jetzt der
bundesfinanzminister und fdp-vorsitzende
schönen guten abend christian lindner
einen schönen guten abend auch jeden der
länder wir haben es gerade eben im
beitrag gehört herr harbecke geht jetzt
voran und macht einen vorschlag für das
kartellrecht verbindet das aber
gleichzeitig mit einer kritik einer sehr
deutlichen kritik an ihrer haltung zur
über gewinn steuer er müsse jetzt
voranschreiten damit man nicht mehr so
lange warten muss bis da der die
diskussion beendet ist das kartellrecht
ändern vorteile abschöpfen können macht
die fdp denn damit das ist sogar ein
auftrag den herr habeck bekommen hat wir
haben hier einen zusammenhang mit dem
entlastungspaket geschrieben dass das
kartellamt in die lage versetzt werden
muss auch die märkte zu kontrollieren
und deshalb schauen wir uns im einzelnen
an geht das jetzt konkret umgesetzt
werden soll aber die richtung stimmt und
ich hoffe dass der vorschlag dieser
sogenannten über gewinn steuer damit vom
tisch ist denn die würde unser
steuerrecht der willkür und den
politischen stimmungsschwankungen
ausliefern das ist vielleicht nicht ganz
einfach zu verstehen über gewinne
abschöpfen in ihrem bereich sagen sie
ist unter anderem willkür anfällig aber
was eigentlich etwas sehr ähnliches zu
machen vorteile abzuschöpfen
und er hat das heute in der
pressekonferenz auch mal über gewinne zu
machen in seinem bereich das finden sie
in ordnung wo ist denn da der
unterschied bei dem steuerrecht haben
wir klare regeln es gibt da gewinne und
es gibt keine über oder unter gewinne
sondern gewinne die in deutschland
übrigens hoch besteuert werden im
internationalen bereich im kartellrecht
muss zunächst einmal ja auch der
nachweis geführt werden dass eine
marktbeherrschende stellung ausgenutzt
wird und sollen die hürden gestern
deshalb ist das etwas anderes und bei
dieser untersuchen für bayer dann auch
feststellen etwa mineralöl- bereich wie
die situation da ist ich glaube eines
kann man sagen die spritpreise wären
ohne die steuersenkung wesentlich höher
jetzt muss man nur schauen der
gestiegene weltmarktpreis der dollar der
stärker als der euro ist die knappheiten
bei den raffinerien und dann die
gewinnmarge der mineralölunternehmen in
welchem verhältnis steht dass ich habe
den eindruck dass die debatte da etwas
emotional aufgeladen ist sie ist auch so
emotional weil die menschen sich sorgen
machen ist mein eindruck das was herr
habe ich jetzt vorgeschlagen hat wirkt
ja nur langfristig die leute schreiben
aber ihnen auch persönlich auf social
media um ihn zu beschreiben dass ihre
maßnahmen eben nicht da ankommen wo sie
benötigt werden wenn sie schon schulden
machen gegen die sie sich so vehement
gewehrt haben im wahlkampf warum dann
nicht so dass die menschen die es
brauchen es auch merken es gibt ja
vorschläge zum beispiel der ig
metall-chef ich darf das mal aufzählen
hat gesagt ein gaspreis deckel bitte er
sagt senkung der strompreise untersagt
ein energie geld bitte auch für rentner
was also zunächst einmal wirken unsere
entlastungsmaßnahmen in der summe eine
vierköpfige familie wird in diesem jahr
um 1000 euro entlastet das ist noch gar
nicht bei den menschen alles angekommen
ist noch gar nicht im portemonnaie da
und das ist ja sind zu ungeduldig das
legen sie mir in den mund ich beschreibe
nur wie die situation ist vierköpfige
familie sind 1000 euro zu 2 sie sagen
auch in dem beitrag wenn sich schon so
viel schulden machen es bleibt bei der
schuldenbremse anders als der eindruck
erweckt worden ist in diesem beitrag ich
stehe unverändert zur schuldenbremse und
im jahr 2023 nach den corona und
kriegsbedingten ausgaben dieses jahres
kehren wir wie geplant darin dahin
zurück dieses jahr galt ja noch von der
vorgängerregierung eine beschlossene
ausnahme und gestalten sie die dritte
bemerkung diese vorschläge wir sollen
einen preis deckel bei energie machen
ich halte diese vorschläge die von der
linkspartei kommen für wie soll ich
sagen
etwas sehr provinziell gedacht denn wir
kaufen unsere energie auf dem weltmarkt
wenn wir versuchen preise festzulegen
ist nicht garantiert dass die weltmärkte
uns beliefert so jetzt leiden ja das tut
zu diesen massnahmen sagen sie nein und
sie sagen auch schulden bleiben so wird
nicht aufgeweicht was sie jetzt machen
lautet die kritik ist nicht besonders
zielgerichtet es gibt den tank rabatt
nur für autofahrer es gibt dass man ein
euro ticket nur für bahnfahrer es gibt
die energie pauschale nur für
erwerbstätige abstufungen nach
bedürftigkeit lehnt die fdp ab und das
ergebnis insgesamt so kommt es bei den
leuten an ist entlastung mit der
gießkanne als liberaler finanzminister
müssten sie da noch alles daransetzen
nachzubessern und zwar zielgerichtet
ihre aufzählung ist allerdings auch
nicht korrekt die empfänger von wohngeld
erhalten einen heizkostenzuschuss
zuschuss für kinder gibt es 100 euro
zusätzliches kindergeld in diesem jahr
und es gibt eine einmalzahlung für die
empfänger von grundsicherung also das
insofern hat bemessen seien sozial ja es
sind weit über 30 milliarden euro und
wir kombinieren gezielte befristete
maßnahmen einerseits wie beispielsweise
die steuersenkung beim sprit und ich
bekenne mich dazu ich mache auch etwas
für autofahrerinnen und pendler die
haben alle anderen nicht im plan mir ist
das wichtig und auf der anderen seite
die menschen die besonders bedürftig
sind das sind vor allen dingen
grundsicherungsempfänger das sind
menschen mit kleinem einkommen die
profitieren ganz besonders von den
maßnahmen etwa von den 300 euro
energiepreis pauschale sie haben es gab
noch mal betont alle der schuldenbremse
wird aus ihrer sicht nicht gerüttelt den
spd-generalsekretär haben wir ganz eben
gehört der sheriff der schulden ganz neu
definiert ist das jetzt in der ampel das
nächste feld wo ein großer konflikt auf
sie zukommt wo sie sich bei der
bekämpfung der inflation und der suche
nach den mitteln nicht einigen können
das weiß ich nicht der bundeskanzler hat
sich ja in seiner letzten rede vor dem
deutschen bundestag zur schuldenbremse
2023 bekannt also insofern muss die spd
vielleicht intern klären wie sie das
seht ich halte mich an den bundeskanzler
und vor allen dingen unser grundgesetz
und ich mache das aus einem guten grund
wir müssen die inflation bekämpfen und
eine der wichtigsten maßnahmen die der
staat hat ist aus den schulden
herauszukommen nicht mit schulden immer
neue subventionen zu zahlen zum beispiel
für elektroautos oder auf die gestiegene
baupreise drauf weil dadurch treiben wir
die inflation wenn man inflation
bekämpfen will dann muss der staat sich
aus den schulden befreien das ist der
beitrag der finanzpolitik und den nehme
ich sehr ernst sagt der
bundesfinanzminister herzlichen dank
christian lindner für das gespräch